ladies and gentlemen please welcome two
great actresses both of them nominated
for Best Actress this evening Thelma and
Louise themselves Geena Davis and Susan
Sarandon
we're here to honor the film editors
some of the most important people in
Hollywood and their skilled hands often
rest the fate of an entire movie that's
true like in our film film and louie's
the way the final scene was edited it
was sort of left ambiguous what really
happened to us in the end and the Jewess
tina our t-bird went off the edge of the
Grand Canyon that's well it's not
exactly ambiguous well nobody saw us Al
and did they know nobody saw the land it
was a priest frame on the car but the
car actually I mean people what did you
think people thought we could have
grabbed on to something yeah went bad
maybe we made it to the other side Susan
if we didn't survive the crash there's
no sequel we could have bounced there
you go action alright so now that we've
settled that the film editors nominated
this year are gerry hambling for The
Commitments Joe Hudson and Pietro Scalia
for JFK Craig McKay for Silence of the
Lambs
Conrad buck mark Lola black and Richard
a Harris for Terminator 2 Judgment Day
Tom no before
and the Oscar goes to Joe hatching in
theaters fully up today
it's rare that a man has the courage to
consistently seek out the higher truth
John F Kennedy was such a man all of her
stone is such a man I I feel very
fortunate to be a part of this project
thank you Alex Howe Jim Garrison Zach
Sklar Juli Monroe
Bill Brown Hank Corwin Bob Richardson
Wiley stateman Mike Minkler John
Williams and my personal thanks to my
parents David Brenner David Nelson
Lauren and thank you phot members Jay
Academy I'm deeply honored making a
movie with Oliver Stone is like going to
battle and JFK was a battle that we all
want Thank You Oliver
I'm very proud to have been a part and
fulfilling your vision and that through
the language of cinema we have opened a
historical debate my deep thanks to
everybody Joe mentioned and to our
assistants Paul Baines and Evan Miller
thank you very much and thank you to my
wife Teresa and my friends and family in
Switzerland Daley who are sharing this
moment with me Jilla five
the next second starring Audrey Hepburn
Demi Moore and Sylvester Stallone